[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in this video we're going
to be discussing anime guy and metamorph
mega and after a brief introduction on
what these two things mean we'll be
dressing number one but to become an
animagus
number two whether or not an animagus
can take the form of well anything is
there a limitation to the form of an
animagus I'll also be briefly touching
on how to register as an animagus an
animagus simply put is a witch or wizard
that is able to transform themselves
into an animal and back again animagus
is a combination of the word animal and
the Greek word make us meaning animal
wizard it is an extremely rare and
difficult ability to master so much so
that it requires you to register your
knowledge of disability with the
Ministry an animagus will typically have
an animal form they transform into that
is closely linked to their personality
and inner traits becoming an animagus
is a learned skill unlike the metamorph
mangas metamorph manga are born with
their amazing ability to change the
physical form at will but differ from
the anime guy in that they are able to
change their physical form in more
specific ways they possess the power to
change their entire physical appearance
but also the ability to hone in on
specific parts of their appearance
changing only those things it is unknown
whether or not metamorph Magus is able
to take on a full animal form as an
animagus wood but in my opinion I don't
think this would be an issue for them
given that they exhibit even greater
control over changing their physical
appearance let's start by taking a look
at some popular characters that are
proven to be anime guy or metamorph
maker number one James Potter the father
of a character that you might know James
Potter was an English pureblood wizard
who is famously murdered by Lord
Voldemort James was a powerful wizard
and achieved the feat of becoming an
animagus
at the age of 15 his animagus form
matched his corporeal Patronus form
which was a tall and powerful red stack
James Navigation ear became an animagus
by way of brewing an animagus potion
successfully number two Sirius Black The
Godfather of Harry Potter series black
like James Potter became an animagus
at the age of 15
he was unregistered he was able to
escape through the bars at Azkaban by
assuming his animagus form number 3
Peter Pettigrew Peter Pettigrew with
lots of help from his friends became an
animagus as well one thing that all the
Marauders had in common was that they
could transform James Potter Sirius
Black and Pettigrew rule and Omega James
could transform into a stag Sirius a dog
and Pettigrew a rat even Lupin could
transform though this was the result of
him suffering from Mike Anthropy number
4 Rita Skeeter Rita Skeeter was a
journalist in which had a bit of a
reputation for being a little dishonest
in her journalistic endeavors while her
stories were largely fabricated they
were usually loosely based off of some
sort of truth or information Gita used
her unassuming and unregistered animagus
form of a Blue Beetle to get dirt on
whatever it was that she was writing
about number 5 Minerva McGonagall
McGonagall was extremely powerful in the
art of Transfiguration and exhibited
extreme ability in the subject in a
variety of forms
she notably mastered the human
Transfiguration branch of
Transfiguration and became an animagus
without too much difficulty animagus
form was a silver tabby cat and she was
known to use this ability when she
didn't want to be seen or recognized
number six Nymphadora Tonks Tonks is the
only metamorph makers on this list and
was born with her ability to change her
physical form it was apparent that she
was a metal wolf make us from the day
that she was born when she changed her
hair color while at school at Hogwarts
Tonks got into trouble quite a few times
transforming into teachers using her
abilities as a metamorph Magus
Tonks was known for constantly changing
her physical appearance and there is
speculation that the emotional state of
a metamorph Magus will affect their
ability to transform transforming a
physical form at will has so many
advantages the most useful of which is
the ability to exist under the radar so
given that it's such a useful skill
shouldn't more witches some wizards be
doing it why aren't they
well first off becoming an animagus is
no easy feat at all Hogwarts
Transfiguration professor Minerva
McGonagall didn't successfully become an
animagus
until she was 17 and that was with the
help of Albus Dumbledore Transfiguration
master Harry Potter wiki describes the
process as follows only very powerful
and skilled Wizards fabled
become anime guy the process of becoming
an animagus is long and arduous and has
the potential to backfire and cause the
transformation to go horribly wrong once
the initial training is over an animagus
can change at will at any time with or
without a wand but how do we do it the
steps are actually outlined on
Pottermore and were explained by JK
Rowling step 1 do your homework in
Transfiguration and potions at least
becoming an animagus requires a witch or
wizard to be skilled in both of these
areas in order to stand a chance of
achieving such a complex transformation
step 2
carry a single Mandrake leaf in your
mouth for an entire month from full moon
to full moon to be precise yes we're
serious if you swallow the leaf or
remove it from your mouth at any point
you have to start the whole thing again
no one likes to see that happen
you then have to find a small crystal
file that receives a pure Rayz of the
moon put your saliva filled leaf inside
and add one of your own hairs step 3
add a silver teaspoon of jus from a
place that neither sunlight nor human
feet have touched for full seven days
and if that wasn't hot enough
you then have to add the chrysalis of a
death's-head hawkmoth to the crystal
file as well then put this mixture in a
quiet dark place and leave it alone
until the next electrical storm and
really leave it alone
don't even look at it don't even think
about looking at it
step 4 while waiting for the storm you
must place your one tip of your heart
every sunrise and sundown and speak the
following incantation amato animo and
Amato animagus if you keep repeating
your incantation there will come a time
when with the touch of the one tip to
the chest a second heartbeat may be
sensed don't change anything keep going
keep waiting for that storm step 5 as
soon as the lightning appears in the sky
go to the place where you've hidden your
crystal file at last if you've done
everything right then you will discover
a mouth full of blood red potion inside
it then move to somewhere where you
aren't going to alarm anyone or place
yourself in physical dangers during our
transformation an animagus
transformation party is definitely a bad
idea step 6
place your 1 tip against your heart and
speak the incantation amato
animo a new motto and make us and drink
the boat
you will then feel fiery pain lucky you
and an intense double heart beat step 7
the shape of the creature into which you
will shortly transform will appear in
your mind
the instructions then warn you must show
no fear it is too late now to escape the
change you have willed
yikes step 8 when the transformation is
complete you are strongly advised to
pick up your wand and hide it somewhere
safe so you can find it post
transformation to return to human form
visualize your human self as clearly as
you can don't worry if you don't change
back immediately with practice you will
be able to slip in and out of your
animal form at will simply by
visualizing the creature once you are
advanced animagus you should be able to
transform without your wand bottom or
also mentions the following things that
you should be wary of when the process
of becoming an animagus goes wrong it
often goes seriously wrong we're talking
horrible half-human half-animal
mutations here with no known cure the
first transformation is usually
uncomfortable and frightening clothing
in items such as glasses or jewelry
melted the skin and become one with fur
scales or spikes when you first
transform try to avoid panicking
otherwise the animal mind may gain the
ascendancy and you could do something
stupid or dangerous generally Wizards
prefer to have their clothes transfigure
with them to escape the embarrassment of
reappearing naked don't forget to log
your personal details and animagus
appearance on the animagus registry
failure to do this might land you in
Azkaban prison so as mentioned above if
you are able to achieve a successful
transformation into your animagus form
you next need to make sure that you
register your animagus status with the
ministry the following quote from
hermione explains this the Ministry of
Magic keeps tabs on witches and wizards
who could become animals there's a
register showing what animal they become
in their markings and things and I went
and looked to Professor McGonagall up on
the register and have only been 7 anime
guy this century only seven known anime
guy seems like a lot of witches and
wizards aren't fessing up once you've
achieved this massive accomplishment the
registration is processed by an employee
the improper use of magic office in the
Ministry of Magic it's not a
certification proving that you have the
skill but merely adding your specific
vote to the ministry list so that they
can keep tabs on you if needed they just
want to know who can do it I guess this
makes sense given that you can
completely slip under the radar
if unregistered so you've become an
animagus and you are now able to
successfully transform into your animal
form in the examples of anime guy above
I discuss the various forms that don't
enna make I assume McGonigle assuming
the form of a cat rita skeeter a Beatle
Peter Pettigrew a rat etc so they assume
one form but one thing that I've always
wondered is if an animagus can be any
animal can they be a dragon a dinosaur
what are the limits first of all your
animators form is not something that you
can choose so immediately
that's out of your control if you were
destined to be a rat than tough luck
next there is a distinct relationship
between our and omegaz form and your
Patronus form the animal into which one
turns if an animagus seems always to be
that which becomes the Patronus so to
confidently answer the question can an
animagus be anything we should first
identify if a Patronus can be anything
this is something that we have a little
more information on according to
Pottermore no reliable system for
predicting the form of an individual's
Patronus has ever been found although
the great 18th century researcher of
charms professor catalase spangle sets
forth through certain principles that
are widely accepted as true the Patronus
asserted spangled represents that which
is hidden unknown but necessary within
the personality here says Bengal is the
explanation for the appearance for
anissa's informs that there caster's
might not expect for which they have
never felt a particular affinity or even
recognized it is usual but not
inevitable for preachers to take the
form of an animal commonly found in the
caster's native country given their long
affinity with humans it is perhaps
unsurprising that among the most common
for turn s's although it must be
remembered that any corporeal Patronus
is highly unusual are dogs cats and
horses extinct patronesses are very rare
but not unknown strangely given their
long connection with the wizard kind
most uncommon of all possible for sure
noses are magical creatures such as
dragons thestrals and Phoenix's while
the rare and magical Patronus
undoubtedly reflects an unusual
personality it does not follow that it
is more powerful
or will enjoy greater success in
defending its Casta from this passage we
can derive that a Patronus can pretty
much be anything sure we more commonly
see animals such as dogs and cats but in
theory they can also be dragons or
chimeras so to answer the question can
an animagus be anything the answer is
yes it can be but it's highly unlikely
that your transfiguration professor is
going to end up being in a crow manchala
and that's it for this video I hope you
enjoyed it if you have further questions
let me know down in the comments section
below until next time you're a wizard
Harry
[Music]